ya hemos hecho algunas condensaciones
alcohólicas y vimos el mecanismo en este
vídeo pensaremos en la reacción inversa
es decir empezaremos con el producto y
aplicaremos la retro síntesis entonces
empecemos con sinama aldehído y hagamos
una reacción retro al dólica el
mecanismo es exactamente el mismo que
usamos para la condensación alcohólica
pero invertido entonces si tenemos una
base como carbonato de sodio formaremos
pence aldehído y acetaldehído este es un
experimento muy interesante porque el
sinam aldehído es la molécula que nos da
ese aroma a canela y el ben's aldehído
huele como almendras así que podemos
empezar con una molécula que huele a
canela y terminar con un
a qué huele como almendras analicemos
nuestros inam aldehído sabemos que el
carbono que se encuentra junto al grupo
carbón y lo es nuestro carbono alfa y el
carbono junto a éste es el carbono beta
también sabemos que tenemos un hidrógeno
unido a este carbono alfa y si rompemos
este doble enlace entonces podríamos
tener nuestro acetaldehído aquí tenemos
2 carbonos este es el hidrógeno unido a
nuestro carbono alfa y también tenemos
otros dos hidrógenos en este carbono por
lo tanto como estamos haciendo la
reacción de forma invertida podemos
pensar en agregar dos hidrógenos solo
escribiré h 2
y después podemos agregar un oxígeno al
carbono beta así que agregaremos h2o
sabemos que hay un hidrógeno en nuestro
carbono beta que corresponde a este
hidrógeno y si agregamos un oxígeno
sería este oxígeno entonces una forma de
ver la reacción invertida es agregando
agua hay que romper el doble enlace y
agregar un oxígeno y dos hidrógenos o
podemos pensar en la reacción al revés
perdemos agua para poder juntar estas
dos moléculas y así obtener nuestro
producto haldol y ccoo la retro síntesis
es muy útil por ejemplo supongamos que
en un examen nos preguntan cómo podemos
sintetizar esta enorme bueno podemos
hacer el mismo análisis que hicimos
antes primero
y picamos nuestro carbono alfa que sería
este carbono y este es nuestro carbono
beta unido al carbono alfa tenemos un
hidrógeno y podemos pensar en romper
este doble enlace dibujemos la flecha de
retro síntesis vamos a romper el doble
enlace así que del lado izquierdo
tenemos nuestro anillo de benceno un
carbón hilo y tenemos un hidrógeno unido
a este carbono que es el carbono alfa
ahora recuerden que agregamos dos
hidrógenos a este carbono esto nos da un
acetona muy bien para el carbono beta
sabemos que hay un hidrógeno justo aquí
y agregaremos un oxígeno entonces del
lado derecho tener
es un grupo carbón hilo
un hidrógeno de color azul y luego
tenemos el anillo finalmente tenemos un
grupo nitro entonces si quitamos agua y
juntamos estas dos moléculas eso nos
dará nuestra en onna conjugada esta es
la forma en que pueden resolver este
tipo de problemas si les dan algún tipo
de condición de reacción pueden dibujar
lo que necesiten por ejemplo supongamos
que necesitamos empezar con esta acetona
y también vamos a necesitar un aldehído
aquí tenemos al 4 nitro benzal de hilo
entonces esta acetona es claro este
compuesto y este es el mismo que este si
tomamos estos dos y los juntamos
formaremos una en onna conjugada porque
recuerden que al pensar en los protones
alfa no hay protones alfa en nuestro 4
nitro benzal de ido este carbono no
tiene protones alfa así que éste es el
único carbono alfa con protones alfa
otra cosa que necesitamos para poder
hacer una condensación alcohólica es una
base podemos agregar algo como hidróxido
de sodio y podemos hacer una solución de
hidróxido de sodio en agua y etanol
entonces si tomamos esta acetona con
este aldehído y usamos estas condiciones
de reacción formaremos es
en una con jugada como nuestro producto
favorecido así es como podemos
sintetizar la usando la retro síntesis
sacamos otro este es un poco diferente
porque ahora nuestro objetivo no es una
enorme sino un haldol pero podemos
pensar de la misma forma primero
identificamos nuestro carbono alfa y
este es nuestro carbono beta y podemos
pensar en romper este enlace también
sabemos que en este carbono hay un
hidrógeno dibujemos nuestra flecha de
retro síntesis podemos ver que del lado
izquierdo
tenemos 1 2 3 4 5 carbonos entonces
vamos a dibujarlos aquí tenemos el
carbón y lo
y nuestros carbonos ya teníamos un
hidrógeno en rosa y esta vez solo
agregaremos un hidrógeno lo pondré de
color verde porque no se encuentra en
nuestro producto entonces solo agregamos
un hidrógeno que más necesitamos bueno
del lado derecho
tenemos un hidrógeno unido a este
carbono y cuantos carbonos tendremos en
el otro compuesto 1 2 3 y 4 4 carbonos
entonces tenemos el carbón y lo
4 carbonos y también tenemos este
hidrógeno entonces ahora al aplicar la
retro síntesis hemos identificado los
compuestos que necesitamos para formar
este haldol como producto así que
necesitamos esta acetona y este aldehído
pero para poder sintetizar este
compuesto necesitamos hacer una adición
al dórica dirigida entonces empecemos
con esta acetona la dibujaré un poco
diferente muy bien a esta zona le
agregaremos en la idea para formar un
heno lato de litio y una vez que lo
formemos podemos agregar un aldehído así
que en el segundo paso podemos agregar
nuestro aldehído que como sabemos es de
4 carbonos agregaremos bután al
esto nos dará un alc óxido de litio que
necesitaremos protones y para eso
podemos agregar un poco de agua así
obtendremos nuestro producto haldol ico
esta es una forma de sintetizar nuestro
haldol es decir usando una adicción
alcohólica dirigida muy bien hagamos
otro como podríamos formar esta molécula
es diferente a la que hicimos antes pero
podemos seguir los mismos pasos este
carbono que se encuentra junto al carbón
y lo es nuestro carbono alfa y junto a
éste tenemos nuestro carbono beta así
que podemos pensar en romper este doble
enlace y agregar dos hidrógenos a
nuestro carbono alfa si pensamos en la
retro síntesis aquí tenemos un anillo
y bueno quizá es más fácil agregar
primero un oxígeno a nuestro carbono
beta lo dibujaré de color verde ahora
aquí tenemos nuestro carbono alfa y
agregamos dos hidrógenos por acá tenemos
nuestro carbón y lo
y otros carbonos asegúrense de contar
bien los carbonos cuando hagan esto
vamos a ver este carbono corresponde a
este carbono y luego este carbono es
este carbono y este carbono en el carbón
y lo es este carbono como podemos ver
esta es una condensación alcohólica
intra molecular si pensamos en perder
agua por aquí y juntamos estas moléculas
formaremos este compuesto de la
izquierda esta es una reacción muy
interesante y podemos redibujar esto
en un examen se encontrarán este
compuesto dibujado de una manera
diferente la verán así identificamos los
carbonos el carbono en rosa corresponde
a este carbono el carbono en azul es
este y el carbono en rojo es este
carbono en el carbón y lo y luego
tenemos a nuestro carbono alfa de color
verde que sería este carbono entonces
este sería el compuesto inicial y si
añadimos una base podemos transformar
esta molécula en este compuesto por
medio de una condensación alcohólica
intra molecular hablaremos más sobre
esto en el siguiente vídeo